oh
[Musique]
bonjour et merci de m'accueillir et
d'avoir cette tolérance pour écouter ce
que je veux vous dire puisque le thème
c'est y at il des limites
je passe et on l'a dit bon j'ai un passé
assez particulier puisque j'ai passé 27
années de ma vie en prison
donc ce qui veut dire que au niveau
limite je les ai largement dépassé pour
meurtre retrouver dans cette situation
mais je vais vous raconter un peu
comment j'ai été amenée justement à
dépasser ses limites et a passé une
grande partie de ma vie dans une cellule
parce qu'évidemment et encore une fois
je ne viens pas ici pour me plaindre je
viens ici pour partager ma propre
expérience par rapport à tout ce que
j'ai vécu parce que en fait quand on
vient on monte on n'a pas tous les mêmes
cartes
ça veut pas dire que ceux qui ont les
mêmes qui n'ont pas les mêmes cartes
peut se permettre n'importe quoi non
sûrement pas c'est juste pour expliquer
que moi je suis né dans un milieu où
justement j'ai pas eu ma place en tant
qu'enfant donc très tôt déjà enfant ça
m'a mis sur un chemin mais qui n'était
pas forcément le mien un enfant est en
droit d'espérer de l'apa bhl de ses
parents de l'amour de la tendresse de
l'affection de la valorisation enfin le
laisser exister
donc ça n'a pas été mon cas moi j'ai
surtout vécu dans des institutions
profond puisque mes parents voulaient
pas vraiment s'occuper de moi donc voilà
c'est pour ça que je vous dis que nous
n'avons pas tous les mêmes cartes
donc voilà ça m'a mis sur un chemin où
j'étais toujours en recherche un peu de
valorisation de tendresse d'attention et
savait j'ai commis mot premier délit à
l'âge de 8 ans donc là j'ai dépassé les
limites c'est vrai qu'à huit ans je ne
me rendais pas vraiment compte que j'ai
dépassé les limites du bien et du mal
donc savoir ce qu'on peut faire ce qu'on
ne peut pas faire moi ce que je voulais
ça me fait remarquer pour avoir voilà
pour pouvoir exister pouvoir regarder
quelqu'un et me dire je compte ce qui
n'était pas le cas et déjà 8 ans voilà
donc j'ai fait un premier vol et en
faisant ce premier vol donc en dépassant
ses limites parce que j'ai eu peur
évidemment parce que j'étais volé des
pièces pour aller acheter des bonbons et
les partager avec mes copains et en fait
quand j'ai fait ça je me suis rendu
compte que j'avais une admiration de la
part de mes copains ce qui n'était pas
le cas avant et moi j'ai bien aimé ce
regard du coup j'ai continué non
seulement d'aller voler les pièces comme
ça mais aussi d'aller voler des petites
voitures dans les grands magasins pour
les donner à mes copains juste pour
avoir ce regard et me sentir exister
voilà encore une fois ce n'est pas une
excuse sens que je vous raconte pour
justifier ce que j'ai pu faire par la
suite c'est juste pour planter le décor
haut niveau le des cartes en un nom
voilà est ce qui fait qu à 13 ans j'ai
commencé à voler des voitures
dès que j'ai été en âge comme ça à 13
ans de me mettre derrière le volant bon
c'était dans les années 60 donc sa rom
en 1960 puisque j'ai 63 ans aujourd'hui
donc ça ça remonte à très loin
et en fait je volais beaucoup de
voitures parce que pour moi j'étais avec
un autre copain qui encore une fois on a
dépassé très vite les limites mais
quelque part sans s'en rendre compte à
cet âge là on sa ronde est pas encore
vraiment content
on savait très bien que ce que nous
faisions n'était pas très clair et pas
bien mais voilà quoi donc c'est des
limites que nous franchissons
allègrement quoi et nous avons volé
beaucoup de voitures une soixantaine sur
deux mois parce que comme je n'avais pas
de sous pour l'essence quand elle tombée
en panne en voulez d'autres
ce qui fait qu'à 17 ans ma placés dans
des institutions ce qu'on appelle des ip
pj donc des instituts publics de
protection de la jeunesse
on appelait ça des maisons de correction
à l'époque et je suis resté là de 13 ans
à 17 ans où l'ag un nouveau dépassé les
limites aux fugues en partant en
recommençant à voler la des voitures en
volant dans les magasins ce qui fait
qu'à 17 ans la juge de la jeunesse
haïtienne me mettre à l'armée pensant
qu'à l'armée on aurait pu me remettre
sur le droit chemin nous servir de ça
comme d'un tremplin pour reprendre un
nouveau départ dans la vie
non non à l'armée j'évoquais et j'ai
volé une arme et avec des copains j'ai
formé une bande et on a été braqué c'est
pour vous dire à certains moments à 18
ans j'étais à la frontière vraiment de
l'acceptable et de l'inacceptable en
ayant une arme en main il ya les ché
dans des banques et tout ça est braquée
là les gens en les menaçant qui s'ils ne
me donnait pas l'argent
non voilà c'est une limite donc
évidemment j'ai été arrêté je me suis
retrouvé en prison en tant qu'adulte
parce que voilà j'avais commis des hold
up et aux lieux encore une fois de me
servir de cette expérience pour
justement essayer de rebondir essayer de
reprendre malgré tout tout en étant
prison le cours de sa vie à essayer de
prendre un nouveau chemin
mais non j'ai encore dépassé les limites
et allègrement au lieu de d'accepter ça
comme une nouvelle épreuve donc positif
dans la vie tout ce que je n'ai pas
trouvé de mieux c'est un nouveau dépassé
les limites et faire entrer une arme à
feu
je fais rentrer une arme à feu et je me
suis évadé de prison
j'ai pris des surveillants en otage
monsieur fait ouvrir les portes et
pendant cette évasion
j'ai dépassé les limites de l'acceptable
puisque j'étais amené avec mon arme en
main a tiré sur des personnes
on est des surveillants de prison que
j'ai blessé par balles trois
surveillants ont été atteints et quand
je me se retrouvait devant la prison la
voiture qui devait le réceptionner
n'était pas là donc j'ai arrêté une
voiture
la personne qui est au volant n'a pas
voulu me donner les clés de sa voiture
je lui tire une balle dans la cuisse
dont vous voyez la frontière de y at il
des limites mais en fait je venais de
les dépasser à ce moment là c'est vrai
que j'aurais pu tuer quatre personnes
juste en mai va dans les passes et les
limites de l'inacceptable
vous allez me dire peut-être là ce
moment là j'ai commencé mais non je
n'avais aucune limite
c'est vrai que c'est seulement ce moment
là que je me suis rendu compte que dans
mon cheminement de délinquants de voyous
mais je ne m'étais posé aucune limite et
j'étais prêt à les dépasser allègrement
même si j'estime que je ne suis pas un
tueur mais j'aurais pu le devenir
c'est vrai que par chance il ya personne
qui est mort de ces coups de feu mais
ont été blessés par balles quand même
donc je veux dire ça n'excuse rien mais
c'est pour ça que je vous dis le dès le
départ c'est pas parce que mon enfance
n'a pas été la même que tout le monde
que st juste ici un peu ce que je suis
devenu c'est parce qu'à un certain
moment savez un enfant quand on lui pose
pas les limites quand il n'a pas une
indication sain et bien équilibré
épanouie
voilà moi j'étais livré très tôt à mon
âme et encore une fois c'est pas pour me
trouver des excuses j'étais livré très
tôt à moi-même et j'ai fait les mauvais
choix
donc moi les limites je ne les ai jamais
posée parce que je n'ai pas été amenés à
les poser et que j'avais moins
l'impression en tant qu'enfant que je
n'avais pas le choix parce que voilà si
je voulais prendre ma vie en main
je devais le faire seul et compter sur
personne évidemment j'ai fait les
mauvais choix savez je me suis retrouvé
avec 40 ans de condamnation et j'étais
pas toujours prêts à changer j'étais
encore prêt à dépasser des limites et
retrouver cette liberté dont je ne
faisais pas grand cas parce que quand je
retrouvais la liberté qu'est ce que je
faisais dehors mais je veux dire passer
à nouveau les limites j'allais encore
volé je me faisais reprendre je me suis
évadé cinq fois cinq fois je me suis
évadé et jamais
je ne suis parvenu à poser ses limites
justement pour m'éviter de de
recommencer mais il s'est quand même
passé un jour un truc dans ma vie c'est
que après 20 ans de prison
j'ai eu l'occasion d'avoir un instrument
de musique en cellule moi je ne savais
pas jouer j'ai pas été à l'école j'ai
fait cinq années primaires
j'ai passé vous si vous voyez ce que
c'est le niveau primaire dont j'ai fait
cinq ans bon la cinquième j'ai fait deux
ans donc une sorte de masters
donc voila quoi et puis je me suis
retrouvé très vite dans les institutions
donc je n'avais aucune indication je
n'ai jamais appris à jouer d'un
instrument tout ça donc c'est en cellule
j'ai une guitare et quelque part un jour
quelqu'un venu frapper à la porte parce
qu'ils avaient entendu le son de la
guitare il m'a dit tiens tu viendrais
pas c'est la messe de noël on a fait une
chorale venir accompagner la les chants
de noël avec ta guitare et vous savez
quoi c'était la première fois qu'on
s'intéressait à moi pour autre chose que
mon statut de voyous et mais fait
délinquance on s'intéressait à moi parce
que je jouais de la guitare c'est tout
bête et en plus cela va frapper à la
porte de ma cellule avant de rentrer ce
qu'on ne fait pas donc moi quelque part
j'ai dépassé mes limites encore une fois
mais dans le bon sens donc j'ai appris
un peu à jouer de la guitare a écrit des
petits textes à écrire des chansons
vous savez ce n'est pas parce qu'une
aumône hier est venu frapper à nos
portes
la veille de noël là miracle s'est
abattue sur moi et que du jour au
lendemain chez devenu un autre homme
non il a fallu 70 travaille sur mon âme
sur notre psychologie la plus profonde
parce que toutes nos personnalités
étaient fortement imprégné de cette vie
de voyou je pensais voyous je dormais
voyou je me réveillais voyous à la
limite je mangeais voyous donc la
mentalité change il faut réapprendre à
vivre normalement
donc pendant sept ans je me suis remis
en question que j'ai dépassé mes limites
encore une fois mais dans le bon sens et
puis j'ai été libéré après 27 années de
prison je me suis retrouvé dehors et que
faire avec ce passé parce que vous
imaginez bien que quand j'ai cherché du
travail
on m'a demandé de certificat de bonne
vie et moeurs on m'a demandé des comptes
et j'ai dû justifier mon absence et sur
mes certificat de bonne vie et moeurs
il fait marquer prise d'otage évasion
tentative de meurtre sur les
surveillants braquage en tout genre
non vous imaginez bien que pour trouver
du boulot c'est vraiment pas évident
mais je me suis accrochée et là aussi
j'ai dépassé mes limites parce que j'ai
parfois été humilié mais je les accepte
et j'ai arrêté de faire la fine bouche
et de me plaindre
et là encore une fois ses limites je les
aient dépassé mais le bon sens donc
j'étais travaillé comme plongeur j'étais
fait la vaisselle dans des restaurants
pendant deux ans parce que je n'avais
pas le choix non plus et puis encore une
fois c'est un travail qui me permettait
de louer un appartement et vous savez là
quand je suis sorti c'est vrai je ne
savais pas trop quoi faire de ce pass
est allé voir un psychologue pour
m'aider tout ça et finalement j'ai
décidé de monter une asbl moi qui n'ont
aucune instruction qui n'est jamais rien
fait de valable dans ma vie j'ai monté
cette est belle parce qu'en fait je
voulais donner la du sens à tout ce que
j'ai fait parce que je me suis rendu
compte que j'étais trop loin
j'étais trop loin et tout ce que j'ai
vécu tout ce que j'ai pu faire aux
autres je ne peut pas l'effacer celle là
c'est imprégné toute ma vie c'est ma
marque et sur ma peau j'ai des tatouages
un peu partout comme dans prison break
mais moi c'est un mauvais plan et nous
voilà quoi c'est quand je suis sorti je
me suis dit je vais créer une asbl dont
j'ai créé une asbl et 7 aces belle pour
but justement de rassembler là des
jeunes qui vont bien des gens qui vont
moins bien et des jeunes porteurs de
handicap et ensemble essayer de faire en
chemin et de me servir justement de se
passer pour les sensibiliser et pis
c'est peut-être éviter à certains de se
retrouver sur le même chemin que le mien
parce que vous savez la délinquance
c'est pas héréditaire c'est pas une
maladie c'est pas un truc qu'on attrape
un c'est un fait de société le parfois
encore une fois pour revenir à cette
fameuse carte que nous avons en main
quand nous venions montrent elles sont
pas les mêmes pour tout le monde quoi
non voilà donc j'essaie de sensibiliser
j'ai même sorti un bouquin qui a été
attaqué directement justice pour le
faire interdire en belgique et dans les
écoles
enfin j'ai gagné le procès n'a encore
une fois j'ai dépassé les limites je
suis quelqu'un c'est vrai qui dépasse
ses limites allègrement avant je le
faisais dans le mal maintenant j'essaie
de le faire dans ce sens là encore une
fois je ne peux pas effacer ce qui s'est
passé mais je sais démontré que la
résilience ce n'est pas qu'un vain mot
comme le disait nelson mandela son
époque qui lui aussi a passé 27 années
de sa vie en prison
ils disent l essentiel dans la vie c'est
ta d'éviter de tomber à tout prix c'est
d'avoir cette capacité de se relever
je pense que j'ai eu cette capacité de
se relever c'est vrai que maintenant il
faut aller encore une fois au delà de
ses limites
parce que vous savez quand vous avez un
passé comme le mien c'est un peu comme
si je traînais derrière moi un boulet
attaché à une chaise et en plus même
quand je parle avec les gens ça se
ressent très vite se passait que j'ai
eus parce que je ne sais pas le cacher
j'ai tellement été imprégné de cette vie
que et voilà et mon pilier mon rang
parce qu'ils me permets moi aujourd'hui
d'être debout devant vous et de
continuer mon chemin
ses 7 aces belle et ce que je fais le
fait de pouvoir partager mon expérience
bon généralement je mets un peu plus de
temps pour raconter mon histoire j'ai
besoin de deux heures au moins
ici j'ai un quart d'heure donc j'essaie
de faire un concentré mais dont voilà
c'est de se dire y at il des limites
mais non moi je pense qu'il y en a pas
j'en avais aucune
et encore une fois si je ne suis pas
devenu un assassin aujourd'hui et même
tueur en série parce que j'aime bien ces
quatre personnes dont j'aurais pu tué
quatre personnes
donc quand on en a mais on en arrive à
tuer personne on est considéré comme un
tueur en série
quoi donc y at il des limites non je ne
pense pas que ce soit dans le bien ou
dans le mal ou dans n'importe quel
domaine
heureusement y'a pas de limites sauf
dans mon domaine c'est vrai que là
j'aurais préféré en avoir donc comme
quoi l'enfance est très importante
quoi qu'on ait pu vivre dans sa vie je
pense qu'on a tous droit à une chance
moi j'en ai une aujourd'hui c'est vrai
que on m'a donné la chance de sortir
parce que j'étais libéré en
conditionnelle et là aussi il me restait
10 ans prison à faire et on a estimé que
voilà il y avait eu un changement dans
mon comportement parce que là j'ai dû
faire des efforts pratiquement surhumain
moi qui n'aimais pas la prison m'a qui
n'aimait pas les surveillants qui
n'aimait pas l'autorité qui était
rebelle à tous révoltés face à tous
qu'ils avaient même de la haine dans le
coeur dont j'ai dû faire vraiment un
travail sur moi même pour aller au delà
de mes capacités au delà des mes limites
pour pouvoir avancer et continuer mon
chemin est resté justement un homme
debout parce que je pense que c'est
important pour moi c'est un saab et
s'agit aussi un peu comme une thérapie
vous savez au fait le fait de parler ça
fait toujours du bien de pouvoir sortir
un peu ce que j'ai en moins
et parce qu'on sort de la de cet univers
très abîmée quoi ils tous les jours
c'est encore une fois une nouvelle
épreuve qui s'ouvre à moi mais savez
quand je me réveille le matin et que je
vois qu'il ya pas de barreaux aux
fenêtres et que les clés sont du bon
côté de la porte mais déjà j'ai un
sentiment de bonheur qui m'envahit et là
je peux me lever et me dire que
finalement la vie est belle quoi et
voilà c'est important de pour moi
j'espère que je ne vous ai pas trop
embêté avec mon histoire j'ai écrit un
bouquin si vous demandez à luca il
pourra le partager avec vous non voilà
et c'est gratuit parce que voilà je ne
le fais plus édité par ce qu'il dit
tiens bouquin c'est 17 euros à l'éditeur
ces cinq oeuvres aux diffuseurs et 33
cents pour moi donc j'ai décidé de le
scanner et de le partager gratuitement
avec tout le monde mon but c'est de
sensibiliser je n'ai pas la science
infuse et pas de solution miracle à la
délinquance
je peux juste sensibiliser et peut-être
avec certains à faire un chemin est
justement de me servir de mon expérience
comme d'un outil pédagogique et pouvoir
de ceux restant sauver 1
donc voilà j'ai plein de projets
jeunesse belge organise des séjours
jusqu'au mans comme je voulais dit avec
des jeunes qui vont bien des jeunes qui
vont moins bien qui sont déjà parfois
sur un chemin glissant et des jeunes
porteurs de handicap qui ne marche pas
j'ai déjoué lettre je laisserais des
petites cartes de visite et ça vous
intéresse
une fois pendant une semaine partager
votre énergie avec ceux qui en ont un
peu moins apprendre à survivre à
s'apprivoiser effet racheté ensemble
n'hésitez pas c'est moi là ce sera avec
plaisir de partager une nouvelle
aventure et peut-être d'aller plus loin
avec moi dans ce que je fais dans
l'ombre que je suis devenu encore une
fois je ne peux pas effacer ce qui s'est
passé mais je peux démontrer que je ne
sais pas une crapule
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]